Everybody My name
is Ryan Johnson,
and I'm a data science
advisor here at Posit.
And welcome to our first
ever Enterprise Community
meetup, where we'll
discuss an end to end data
science workflow
using Posit Team.
So this will be a
recurring event.
We'll probably have it the
last Wednesday of every month
and we hope it will serve as
a good primer for those that
are new to Posit Team but also
help current Posit Team
users become more
familiar with our tools.
And every month we'll
cover a different topic
and will highlight all three
tools within Posit team.
So Posit Workbench,
Posit Connect and Posit
Package Manager.
And then after
each presentation,
we'll have a casual
discussion where
folks can ask us questions,
Posit questions,
or we can just discuss workflows
with other community members.
So with that, let's go
ahead and get started.
And I first want to
start and make sure
that everyone on the call
is familiar with Posit team
from a high level.
So this is Posit team.
We're going to start
up here at the top
with the data scientists, the
data analysts, the folks that
are actually writing code.
And many times their job
is to create insights
and to share those insights.
So let's start by
going to the left
here and creating insights.
They're going to
be writing code.
They can use R
python, they can use
whatever ID they want, either
RStudio Jupyter Lab, Jupiter
Notebooks, VS Code all
within Posit Workbench.
So Posit Workbench is our
server base implementation
of the various
IDEs and your data
scientists are writing code
again in whatever language
they want.
So if you're within r, they
might be creating things
like Shiny applications,
pins R markdown, plumber,
but if they're
Python developers,
they might be creating things
like flask or Fast API streamlit,
dash, bokeh applications,
Jupyter Notebooks.
Maybe they're also creating
Quarto documents, which
is one of our newest tools.
So when they create
content like this,
it doesn't do anyone
any good if they
can't share it with the
people that need to see it.
And that's the whole
purpose of Posit
connect our second tool
within Posit team.
This is our professional
publishing platform
and this makes it super easy to
share all the cool content you
see here with the people
that need to see it,
like your boss, decision
makers, maybe your self, maybe
your friends or family.
You can share it
with Posit connect.
So for today's session
we're primarily going
to live within Posit
Workbench and Posit connect.
But there's also one other
tool we'll touch upon today
and that's Posit
Package Manager,
and it does pretty
much as it name
is, name implies
it helps control
all those great open source
packages within R and Python.
Also any, you know, packages
you've created yourself
within Workbench and connect.
So we'll talk about all
three of these tools
today that again
Round out Posit team.
Now for today's
session, we are actually
going to live within
the code, so we're
going to go into Posit
Workbench and we're
going to open up
a VS Code session
and we're going to
go through an example
where we take a dash application
it's actually a dashboard.
We're going to publish
it to Posit connect
and share it with
everyone here on the line.
So we're going to go primarily
live within Workbench
and connect today and then we'll
touch upon package manager.
So this dash
application is actually
built into our
Jumpstart examples
you'll find when you first
log in to Posit connect.
So when you log in can
click on R or Python.
So you have Python selected.
And you can see a variety
of other examples.
But we're going to treat this
stock pricing dashboard, which
is a dash application,
and this is just
a screenshot of what
some of that content
looks like within
that dash application.
So again, we're
looking at stock prices
of a few different stocks
you can choose from.
And we'll get the chance
to explore this application
once we actually deploy it.
So with that, let's go
ahead and get started.
So I'm going to be leveraging
our demo server here
at Posit
We have our three
professional tools right here
and let's go ahead and start
within Posit Workbench.
So I'm going to go ahead and
open this up in a new tab.
And when you first log
into Posit workbench,
this is the screen, you're going
to see on the right hand side.
I have various, R,
RStudio projects
that I've been working on.
And I can easily click on one
of them and jump right back in,
or I can start up a
brand new session.
So let's go ahead and do that.
And this, again, is one of
the best parts about Posit
Workbench is that no matter what
your data science team uses,
The preferred IDE the hope is
that we can support it here
within Posit Workbench.
So we currently support
Jupyter notebook, Jupyter lab,
the RStudio IDE as well.
And then we have
the VS Code editor,
which is a great all
purpose editor, which is
what we're going to use today.
So I'm going to click on VS
code and when we do that, we
get some additional options.
So I can give this VS
Code session a name.
I'll just leave it as
a default right here.
And then right
underneath, you're
going to see
Cluster Kubernetes.
Now, to tell you a little bit
more about our demo environment
here, at Posit it is
all hosted in AWS,
Amazon Web services, and it's
in a high performance computing
cluster, an HPC environment,
and that environment
is managed using something
known as Kubernetes.
So some of you may have
heard of Kubernetes.
That's one of these HPC
managers that we support.
If you also use Slurm, we
can support that as well.
Or you can also just run these
tools on a single server.
That's totally fine as well.
But one of the advantages of
using Kubernetes or Slurm is
you can actually control
this job's CPU and memory
allocations.
So if you just have
a small job, you
want to maybe create a plot
or a simple application.
You can keep the CPU
low, keep the memory low,
and that's just great for
managing compute resources.
But if you have a higher
compute, more demanding job,
I can bump that up.
For example, I can
change in memory as well.
So really good at
managing resources.
Then you'll see this
last box right here.
This is the image box.
So I have the option to choose
a specific Docker image here
to deploy this
session so that I can
help control additional
environment variables.
Things like what R
versions are available,
Python versions,
what packages are
installed by default that
can all be controlled
using various Docker images.
But I'll just stick to
the default for right now.
That all looks good.
Let's go ahead and
start the session.
So once they do that, you can
see this session is starting.
And one of the other
advantages of Posit Workbench
is if I want to start another
session the exact same time,
I can do that.
I can have more than one
VS Code session going.
I can have an RStudio
session going.
I can have a Jupyter we'll
open a Jupyter notebook
session going.
And this is a great way.
If you're working
on multiple projects
using different languages
and different IDEs,
you can have them all
going simultaneously
and easily switch between
the four that I created here.
So we're going to open up
this VS code session.
You can see down
here at the bottom
and we'll just have that
ready once we get the dash
application going here.
All right.
So here's vs code again
running on Posit Workbench.
On the left hand side,
we see my File Explorer
and I've already created
a blank directory.
There's nothing in it.
I have called it
Quickstart and this
is where we're going to
house that dash application.
We're eventually
going to deploy.
And then we have that get
started guy that pops up
all right, this
close out of that.
All right.
So we are ready.
We're ready to create
this dash application
and eventually deploy
it to Posit connect.
So where are we going to
find this dash application?
So coming back to our demo
environment of Posit team here,
we've already started
within Workbench.
Let's go ahead and
open up, Posit connect.
So when you click
on Posit connect
or open up Posit
connect, you'll
see this screen that pops open.
These are Jumpstart
examples right here.
And you can see there's
a variety of content
for R related content.
So R Markdown parameterized
R Markdown Plumber API,
Shiny apps, pins, you can choose
any of these to get started.
You can also select
various Python content
that's supported by connect.
So Jupyter notebooks,
das, bokeh, streamlit,
various other ones
Python Shiny application,
which is one of our newest
supported applications,
but for today's demo.
We're actually going to
stick with this stock pricing
dashboard and probably
for future sessions,
we'll probably focus on some
of these other jumpstart
examples, but we thought
this would be a great place
to start.
So we're going to
go ahead and we're
going to send this download
this dash application.
We'll put it on Posit
Workbench and then
we'll deploy it
to Posit Connect
So let's go ahead
and get started.
So with the jumpstart
examples, the first thing
that we need to do is we
need to download the files
for this dash application.
So we have a download button.
I'm going to download
it to my computer.
And then I'll click
on Next right here,
and it says to unzip
this file that we just
downloaded locally, and
then we can basically
move on to the next step.
But I'm going to go
ahead and open this up
within Posit Workbench.
So let me switch
back over to VS Code
again, running within
Posit Workbench.
I want to grab that file that
I just downloaded and I'm
going to drag it over
here to my file directory.
And now we have
that zip file that
just downloaded from
that jumpstart example
within VS code on
Posit Workbench.
Now with first thing you
need to do is unzip this file
and gather all of its contents.
And we're going to do
this using the terminal.
So I'm going to click on this
button, the top left corner.
I like to call it
a burger button.
Click on that.
You'll see terminal,
new terminal.
All right if I do print
working directory just
to see what directory I'm in.
You can see I'm in that
Quickstart directory.
And if I do ls to list all
the files in that directory,
it just has that
single zip file.
So let's go ahead and unzip it.
So I'm going to
run unzip and then
we'll just give it the name of
that zip file and hit Enter.
And that's actually going
to unzip the contents
within a separate directory
called stock-dashboard-python.
So I'm going to go ahead and
navigate into that directory.
So cd, change directory,
cd-stock-dashboard-python.
I'm going to clear my screen.
I can do that on my keyboard
using Control L and ready print
working directory.
Now you can see I'm within
that directory, that
file that we just unzipped and
I can click on it right here.
And we can see all the
contents and right here.
App.py
This is the dash application
that we are going to run
and deploy to Posit
Connect all right.
So let's come back
to Posit connect
and keep working our
way through those steps
to the jump start example.
The first thing we need to do
is install the required packages
using something
known as pip, which
is a typical installer for
installing Python packages.
And we're going to
use pip to install
all of the packages that
live inside this file
requirements.text.
So let me come back to
VS code and just show you
what that file looks like.
So over here on
the left hand side,
you can see
requirements.txt.
These are all of the libraries,
the Python libraries that I
need to basically run
this dash application
and the necessary versions.
All right.
So this is kind of a
good for my environment,
making sure that all of these
are present to appropriately
deploy this dash application.
So let's go ahead and make sure
all these packages are there.
I'm going to copy this command
from the jumpstart example,
come back to the code,
hit Paste and enter.
It's going to print
some logs to my screen.
You can see a lot of these say
requirement already satisfied.
So that's good.
It looks like that these
packages, for the most part
were already present
in my environment.
But I want to take
a quick pause here,
and I think it's
worth noting or trying
to determine where am
I actually looking when
I go to install these packages?
And that's where package
manager, Posit package
manager is going
to come into play.
So if you look on this line
right here looking at indexes,
it provides a URL.
This is actually a URL
to our demo Posit package
manager instance.
So we come back to
our demo environment
and let's explore package
manager a little bit.
Now, for the most
part, package manager
is a tool used by your system
administrators or IT team
to help set up the package
environment for workbench,
for Connect, for your developers.
But there is a user
interface that developers
can log into and see what
packages are available to them.
So let's get started.
So here's the user
interface, and I first
want to have everyone take a
look on the left hand side.
And over here, you
can see various
R repositories that are set
up in this instance of package
manager.
So things like a
CRAN mirror, for example,
or any internally
developed R packages.
We also consider bio
conductor packages.
So if anyone's doing any genomic
analysis, high throughput
data, a sequencing
data analysis,
you might be familiar
with bioconductor,
but for today's
demo, we're going
to focus in on Python
repos and there's currently too.
In this example, package
manager instance,
we see pypi and
local Python.
So just to describe
what local Python is,
if you're creating any of
your own Python packages
and you want to share
them with your team,
you can upload them to your
instance of package manager,
and make it super easy for
anyone else on your team
and your company to
leverage that package.
And then you see pypi and pypi is
one of the largest rePositories
for Python packages.
And you can explore all the
various packages currently
within pypi.
So for example, I
can search numpy,
which is a pretty popular data
science package within Python.
We can get some
information about it,
like how to install
it, what it requires.
So Python version has
to be greater than 3.8.
What's the most recent version.
And some other
information as well.
But how do I pull in numpy
from this instance
of package manager from
this pypi repository.
So by selecting pypi you
can see the name right here
in the top left corner.
We're going to go to the Setup
tab and talk a little bit more
about how to leverage
package manager.
So I'm going to scroll down
just a little bit here.
And you're going
to see this url,
use this URL to receive
the latest source packages.
So when you go to
install a package,
if you install
from this url, it's
going to pull in from this
repository on your instance,
Of package manager.
And for example, this is our
again our demo environment
of Posit package manager.
And then to just a
few other cool things
you can do with package manager.
You can see in the path here.
Latest by using
this url, I'm always
going to pull in the latest
and greatest version of numpy,
for example, but
maybe that's not
exactly what you want to do.
Maybe you have a project
that you worked on a year ago
and you want to go
back into that project
and you want to install packages
as they were a year ago.
And that's where this
Calendar comes into play.
So I can go All the way back,
let's say December 1st, 2021.
If I click on that date, you
can see the URL has changed
and now the date is
reflected in the path.
And if I install a
package using this url,
it'll install it as if
it's December 1st, 2021.
And then if you ever want to
learn how to actually leverage
this URL in your
instance of VS code
or wherever you're doing
your Python development,
we have some instructions
right down here
to install sort of one off
packages from package manager
or have it set
more persistently.
So any packages you ever install
will always use this URL.
And that's what I pretty
much done in my environment.
So that's package manager.
So let's come back
here to connect.
So we've already done this step.
We've installed
all those packages
we made sure there and
available, available
using this requirements
dot text file.
Let's move on to the next step.
And now you're going to install
this rsconnect Python package.
This is the actual
package that's
used to deploy Python
content to Posit connect
and we're going to install
it using pip again.
So pip install rs
connect Python package.
So I'm going to go ahead and
copy this command, come back
to the code.
I'm going to clear
my screen just
to make it a little bit cleaner.
So Control L paste
and hit Enter.
Again, you can see it's pulling
from that same instance,
of Posit package manager
and our demo environment.
And for the most part,
it looks like everything
that this package
depends on, the package
itself was already satisfied.
It's already present
in my environment.
So that's great.
So clear my screen here,
come back to connect
and let's move on to
the next step, which
is really the last step.
We are going to go ahead and
deploy this application using
the rsconnect Python package.
Now there's a note right here.
You will need to create
and use an API key in order
to deploy your
Python application.
And this is important
because when
you deploy to Posit
connect using this package,
the rsconnect Python
package connect needs
to know who's actually trying
to deploy it, make sure you have
the necessary credentials
and the privileges
to actually deploy
to that instance.
Of Posit connect.
So right here is the
command that we're
going to use to deploy
our dash application.
I'm going to go ahead and copy
it, bring it on over to VS Code
again, running in Posit
Workbench and just paste it.
I'm not going to
run it just yet,
but let's run
through this command
because it reads pretty
easily from left to right.
So we're using that rs
connect Python package.
So this function right here
to deploy a dash application
to this server, this
instance of Posit connect.
And then you can see this
next argument API key.
And then there's some
placeholder texts right here.
So this is where you're going
to supply that API key to let
connect know that, hey,
it's me deploying this dash
application to that
instance of Posit connect.
So where do we
find this API key?
Let's go back to Posit Connect,
which I've already logged into.
I'm going to close out
this jumpstart example
because we're pretty much done
with it for the most part.
And I'm going to go
over here to My name
in the top right corner.
And you'll see API keys.
So you click on API
keys and you can
see I've already created about
four or so API keys if you
need to create a brand new one.
You just selected
this box right here.
Copy that API key.
Come on back over
to vs code running
and Posit Workbench and
paste it right here.
Now API keys just
always treat just
like you would any passwords
so you want to make sure
they're nice and safe.
I've actually already added
this to my environment,
so I'm just going to
delete this argument
and the rsconnect Python
package will automatically
detect it when it
runs this command
and then the last
little bit this ./
here is rs
connect will automatically
detect this API application in
the directory and deploy it.
So that's it.
This is the command.
We'll hit Enter and
we'll let it run.
So let's say I may have.
Let me just check the
print working directory.
Right one more time.
I got to delete the API key.
There you go.
And hit Enter there we go.
So it's going
through a few checks
right here, like
validating the server
and making sure that
bundle looks good.
Everything seems to be in order.
OK if anything is
not in order, it
should print some nice
useful messages for you
to help troubleshoot.
But what's actually
happening right now?
Like when you deploy
this application?
What's going on?
So for the most part, it's
capturing my environment.
It's looking to see what
Python version am I using,
what libraries am I using,
what versions of the libraries.
So you can see like
right here, for example,
all these various Python
libraries and their associated
versions, it's
making sure connect
has those packages and
the appropriate versions
on the server and can replicate
my environment exactly as
it's laid out here.
Once it's established,
it can then
deploys that
dash application.
So you can see deployment
completed successfully.
And it gives me two
links right here.
We'll select that top
one, click on this.
And it's going to bring us
right to Posit connect.
And while this is running,
kind of setting up right
here, you'll notice
as a publisher,
I have this little gear icon
in the top right corner.
And these are some
additional controls
I have as a publisher of
this dash application.
But here it is.
This is the dash application
now hosted on Posit connect.
And we can try it out.
We can hover our
mouse over here.
Some of the plots you
can see a little pop up.
I can choose another
stocks let's try Google.
You see that one
pops up as well.
Scrolling down has a few
other interactive plots
and visualizations, so
here I could Zoom in
on a specific date.
This plot is pretty cool.
I can select certain
points and you
can see those points being
selected in the companion plot
or to the left here.
Kind of a cool
cross talk feature.
And then we also have a
table over here as well.
So this is the dash application.
Now, again, as a publisher, I
have some additional controls.
And the most important
thing is I'm a publisher.
How do I then share it with
the people that need to see it?
And that's going to be right
here under access controls.
Now we have it set by default
to specific users or groups.
And if you look
right underneath,
you can define those users
and groups right here.
I'm currently the only one
that can view this content.
But let's say, for example,
I want to give Rachael access.
Now, we would be the only two
that can view this content.
So really tight control
over who you want
to share this application with.
Which is great, especially if
you have any sensitive data.
But we can be a
little less strict.
So if you look at the
middle option right here,
all users log in required.
If I select this,
basically, as long
as you can log in to
the Connect instance,
you can view this content.
So here at Posit is
our demo environment.
That's pretty much all
Posit employees.
They can log into
the Connect instance.
They can view it.
But we can be even less
strict and select anyone.
No login required.
And if I do that, basically this
application, this dashboard,
we created when
hosted on Connect
is opened up to the world.
So if anyone has this URL
in the top of the screen,
you see right here, they
can view this content.
Now, if you look
at this url, you
can see it's not the prettiest
URL or some random letters
and numbers up here.
We can change that.
We can give you some
more customized URL.
I come down here at content
URL and I can just dash app and hit
Save.
And now we have
this customized URL
at the bottom of
the screen, which
we can then share with
the world and anyone
can view this content.
So let's talk about a few of
the other options you have,
again, as a publisher.
You have tight control
over this dash application.
And the next one we'll
go to is runtime.
And this is where you can
control the compute resources
or Python processes
supporting this application.
If it's a real
lightweight application
doesn't require a
lot of compute power,
you can keep it very low.
But if you have an
application that's
maybe crunching some
large data or training
a model, for example,
you might want
to allocate some additional
Python processes.
So there are Python processes
supporting this application
while it's running.
We can define a minimum number
of processes, a maximum, which
you can see here set
to three, and then you
have max connections
per process.
Now if I share that
link with somebody
and they click on that link,
they become a connection
to this application.
So by default here I can
have up to 50 connections
and up to three processes,
so I could support up
to 150 concurrent users.
Now, that may be perfect
for what you need.
Maybe you want to tweak it
and you can do that again.
As a publisher, you
don't have to worry
about your administrators
and talking to them
and configuring it.
You can do it as a publisher.
So, for example,
I can come in here
and I can give it 10 more
additional processes.
And then in this
configuration, I
can support up to
500 concurrent users.
So 50 connections per process
and up to 10 processes.
So again, that's how you can
control it as a publisher.
A few additional options
here along the top,
the Scheduling tab.
This actually does not apply
to interactive content.
So things like dash streamlit,
bokeh or within the R ecosystem
like Shiny applications.
So scheduling jobs
doesn't necessarily
apply to interactive content,
but if you are deploying things
like R Markdown or Jupyter
Notebooks or even quarto
documents, you can actually
place code in those documents
and schedule them to run.
So this is great.
If you have any recurring
jobs, maybe every morning
when you come in, you
can actually place them
into any of those
documents I just
mentioned hosted on Connect and
you can schedule to run however
frequently you want.
And then just to round
out the last two here
tags are just for
organizing your content.
So if you have maybe a study
or a project you're working on
and there's a variety of
pieces of content associated
with that project,
you can create a tag
to help easily organize and pull
up that various content types.
And the last one here is vars.
If your content requires some
type of privileged access
to a database or an
API, for example,
you can come into the
vars tab right here
and supply that
password or API key.
So the application
has those credentials
to access that database
or API, for example.
All right.
So that's pretty much it.
And just to recap again
what we did today,
we started in Posit Workbench.
We created that vs code session.
We downloaded the
dash application
from the jumpstart
example hosted in connect.
So that stock example.
And then we went
through the process
of deploying that application
to Posit connect
and then sharing
it with the world.
And as we did that, we
were installing packages
from our instance of
Posit package manager.
So hopefully this Posit
team overview was helpful
and we're just going to
go ahead and open it up
to any questions from the
audience, general discussion,
and we'd be happy to answer
any questions anybody has.